hello everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia I'm
very proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2023 2024 foundations
biomedical data science seminar series
the lecture series is supported by uva's
integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA College of
Arts and Sciences the UVA School of data
science and through a grants from the
National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of
biomedical data science seminar Series
has focused on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to different themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences our
theme this year is focus focused on
building Partnerships for generative AI
training in biomedical and clinical
research where every Friday we enjoy
presentations from a wide range of
leading thinkers about the issues
promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with the emerging Trend in AI
based methods indeed we'd like to remind
folks that our 2023 2024 application
cycle is still open for another few
hours and we encourage Junior faculty
members working in area such as the
development of generative AI based
methods applied to biomedical research
and those Junior faculty actively
utilizing Ai and their biomedical
teaching to consider applying we believe
this will is an exciting and engaging
program which this year will bring
together AI platform developers
University level Educators to better
understand the power the promise and the
potential pitfalls associated with the
generative AI explosion participants
selected for our biomedical data science
Innovation lab program will Leverage
these seminar presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
manuscript and Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the lovely Bahia
beachfront Resort located in Sunny San
Diego California in June of 2024 and
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr James zo uh from Stanford
University James is an assistant
professor of biomedical data science
computer science and electrical
engineering at Stanford University he is
also the faculty director of the
Stanford AI for health program and he
works in both improving the foundations
of machine learning by making models
more trustworthy reliable as well as
in-depth scientific and clinical
applications many of his Innovations are
widely utilized in technology and the
biotechnology Industries and he has
received a Sloan Foundation Fellowship
an NSF career award two chan chan
Zuckerberg investigator Awards and a top
10 clinical Achievement Award several
best papers Awards and a whole bunch of
other Awards as well and in continuing
with our 2023 2024 biomedical data
science seminar series theme uh James's
talk today is going to be entitled
biomedicine in the age of generative Ai
and James is going to note that we have
there have been tremendous advances in
generative AI in the context of chat GPT
do and various other um generative AI
systems and his talk is going to explore
how these models can power biomedical
discoveries by expanding the design
space of Medicine while balancing
complex trade-offs and he'll illustrate
several examples and then he'll apply a
similar generative AI approach to guide
the design of of clinical trials and
show us how that can be done as always
we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2023 2024 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have via the chat feature
in their YouTube sessions I will
synthesize these questions and I will
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of James's lecture and
James with that welcome we are so
excited to be hearing from you and we're
really looking forward to your
presentation all right great well thank
you very much for the introduction and
for organizing this Jack and really nice
to see everyone so I'm James so uh and
I'm excited to discuss and share with
some of you some of the recent
developments in developing and applying
generative AI approaches across the fun
B Medical
applications all right so we seen really
exciting advances in general of AI
especially over the last year year and a
half right so for example in the area of
art right so people now have these great
tools for typing in some descriptions of
images and then having the models to
generate images that they want to see
right in the another area of gener AI
That's tremendous Advan right so people
have been using models like ch BT in
your everyday lives and in addition to
chbt now there is a whole ecosystem of
large language models and are new models
that are coming out you know on every
every week or every couple
weeks and these kind of models and
general AI tools have also been very
useful in biomedical research and
education right so for example I was
teaching a class recently at Stanford
for students like looking into
computational biology right and it's a
part of the class right so we
actually um help the students basically
use tools like gp4 to help them to
generate analysis code right and with
the help of gp4 the students were able
to actually replicate some of the quite
complex analysis that were published in
some of the original pioneering papers
uh but now using the help of gbd4 to
replicate this analysis in a much
shorter amount of time right this also
gives them more more time to look into
the more in-depth outcomes and
interpretations of the data
right so what I want to discuss today
right is really some of the thoughts on
like what really makes gender VI
different and how do we really leverage
these tools um for biomedical
applications and if we first take a step
back right so like how is generative AI
actually different from other kinds of
AI or machine Learning Systems right so
if you think about the more standard
statistical machine learning models
right these models are usually meant to
make predictions right regression
problems or classification problems and
in the setup of these models right so
you have some input the model could
still be a pretty complicated multi Neal
Network or your favorite machine
learning models but typically the output
of the model is usually relatively
structured or relatively simple right if
I'm making a regression problem let's
say I'm trying to predict the survival
outcome of a patient right usually the
output would be a single number
correspond to survival time but making
like a classification problem the
outcome then could be maybe one of a few
classes that are fixed ahead of
time right in contrast right if I look
at the recent generative models right
the outcomes the outputs of these models
are typically much richer and much more
complex instead of having a few
categories or a few scalar numbers right
the output of these n of models could be
images like we saw in the first slide it
could be molecules which I'll explain
next it could be code right analysis
code or software itself and the models
themselves can also be specially subst
be larger than the models that we used
before in terms of the number of
parameters right so from that
perspective then right really the way I
think about generative AI is that it's
less about making specific predictions
but it's more about actually designing
right this helping us to explore this
more complex space of uh know of images
of molecules of code of algorithms right
and helping us to really design these uh
outputs uh design these complex
objects
and today I want to explore this idea of
design right enabled by generative
models and in particular want to see how
does these AI generated designs can help
to facilitate biomedical applications
and
translations and I think biomedical
translation pipeline is an especially
good application area right for Gen AI
because typically when we think about SM
bical translation we have to balance
these quite complex trade-offs right
trade-offs like uh the cost of
experiments right the efficacy of the
experiment the safety toay
s and when we think about this entire
pipeline right all the way from early
stage Discovery right we're doing drug
Discovery or Target Discovery to later
stages of clinical trials all the way to
uh postclinical settings where at every
step they involves some complex designs
to balance these multi-dimensional
objectives so today I want to give some
concrete examples of how we can actually
use gender of AI to help us to improve
our designs across this entire pipeline
right from early stages right I'll show
you example of how we actually use gen
to help us to explore the space of new
molecules to design new mod new drugs
and in the middle after we have these
new drugs we need to design clinical
trials right to effectively evaluate
these drugs so I also explore how we can
use these generative approaches to help
us to design more inclusive and more
diverse clinical trials and you know
after even after the drugs come on the
market right there's still questions
around how do we assist Physicians
clinician try to figure out what drugs
to use how to diagnose patients and what
drugs to use for given patients so the
last part I will explore is how to use
gen models to basically provide clinical
assistant tools for for clinicians and
um and phys uh and uh and
researchers okay so so so this will be
the three parts of the presentation
today so we start dive in uh looking the
first part right which is thinking about
how to use gener AI models for Designing
new drugs and I want to give you a
concrete example um of how to use this
tools to design new
antibiotics um the the kind of
algorithms I'll describe will be quite
General so they can be used to do other
kind of small molecule drug Discovery um
but I want to give a concrete example of
antibiotics because it's I think really
an urgent uh and high impact problem all
right so many of you know that know
antibiotics discovered uh in the 20s was
Penicillin and what's interesting is
that if you at the history of
antibiotics right the first few decades
after peninsulam there's actually a sort
of a gold rush where a lot of new
antibiotics new molecules being
discovered and put on the market but
it's important to know that basically
for the last 60 years there are actually
relatively few structurally novel
antibiotics that people were discovering
and then bringing into the
market and this is a problem right
because if we don't have a lot of
different diverse kinds of antibiotics
then it becomes easier for bacteria to
develop resistance to the existing
antibiotics right and the fact that
bacteria have developed resistance to
many of the existing antibiotics is
currently a major Public Health crisis
right so currently over a million people
die every year because they're exposed
to bacteria that have developed
resistance and that number is
unfortunately expected to really
increase quite a bit over the next few
years right and this is for illustrated
by this timeline here that's shown here
in the bottom right where above the
timeline indicates when the first time
when a new antibiotic drug is first
introduced and brought into the market
and the bottom corresponds to when we
first observe resistance right to that
drug and the main takeaway here is that
in many of these cases right there's
only a really relatively short lag
between the introduction of the drug and
when resistance develops which really
highlights the fact that we have This
ferocious arms race right between drug
developers and pathogens and because
we're not discovering as many new novel
antibiotics right so we're really losing
at the risk of losing this arms race as
a consequence now we have these bugs
like this one called here aoac bani it
doesn't look very uh dangerous but it's
actually an extremely dangerous uh
pathogen uh it's considered by world uh
by experts to be the perfect Predator
because it has developed resistance to
many of the existing uh drugs that we
have
right so in this first example I want to
give is I want to describe how we
actually use turn of AI to help us to
discover new novel small molecules right
that have then we've experimented
validated to be effective in in killing
this uh dangerous
pathogen okay so here's the here's where
geni comes in right so the idea here is
that we want to use these AI models
right to help us to explore the vast of
space base of small molecules so small
molecules are typically the most common
kinds of drugs that that we have uh and
many of them have been tested and being
synthesized but if we look at the actual
space of potential small molecules right
so the we have only ever experimentally
tested a very small sliver of all the
possible small
molecules and this is where I think AI
can be very helpful is to help us to
explore this Vass of space of the
universe of small molecules especially
of Novel mole that we haven't actually
seen before or experimentally tested
before and help us to decide and create
new molecules that then we can
synthesize and test all right so I have
a fantastic PhD student Kyle Swanson
who's a student working with me at
Stanford and he he developed this really
nice pipeline uh which I'll describe
next for using gender AI approaches uh
including some reinforcement learning
approaches for developing and
discovering these new small
molecules but first I think the Big
Challenge right in using generative AI
for drug Discovery is the following
right it's actually relativly easy for
generative AI models to generate know
hypothetical molecules know they can
hallucinate new molecules but actually
but the hard part is we don't know how
to make these molecules right it's easy
for the algorithm to come up with some
new molecules that nobody has seen
before right but if we don't know how to
make those molecules then that doesn't
really help it doesn't really Advance
drug
Discovery so then what we want to do in
KY Alm is that we don't want to just
have the AI model to create new
molecules but we want to ask the gener
AI model to help to generate new
molecules and also the recipes to
explicitly make each of these new
molecules right so here's one of what we
mean by a recipe for synthesizing new
molecules right so sort of like a
cooking recipe right so you start with
of building blocks which are sort of
small fragments of molecules that are
easy to create and we know how to make
these building blocks
and then uh we can apply chemical
reactions there's no list of well-known
chemical reactions each reaction you can
think that this is basic being like a
template that can be applied to a subset
of these building blocks right so in
this reaction I apply it to these two
building blocks and then the output of
the reaction will be like a larger more
complex molecules right and you can also
apply a sequence of different reactions
to create even more complex molecules so
this is sort of like the space of
potential molecules that we can
potentially synthesize and explore and
so a huge space right because know we
have on the Waters of hundreds of
thousands of fragments and there also
know maybe hundreds of reactions that
people know how to work with and if you
apply these in different combinations
you can quickly see that we have this
really exponentially large space of
potential
molecules and in the space of potential
molecules right it's worth emphasizing
that people have only ever tested and
built constructed only a very small
subset of the potential
molecules so this is where the AI comes
in right so we want to basically use the
AI model to help us to create this
recipes where where each recipe then
will be a step by step of instructions
of taking for example different building
blocks apply reaction one and then apply
reaction two where to create a new
molecule so the way that we model this
uh through the AI algorithm is through
this basically what we call a multicol
tree search as this is inspired by some
of the recent uh evanes in AI That's
used to play games right like for
example there's a famous AI Alm called
Alpha go which is very good at playing
go and it's also similar Al for playing
chess and the way that these game plane
a algorithms works is that know they
basically model the game as a huge space
a tree of potential moves right and then
use the AI to sort of explore that space
of potential moves so in our setting we
also have this huge tree right where
instead of the notes being the potential
moves that you can make in chess or go
the notes now corresponds to different
MO
fragments so let me explain that in a
bit more uh uh detail right so we first
start from the level one of the tree and
then we go down right so the level one
of the tree corresponds to the building
blocks individual building blocks right
again each building block are one of
these small fragments that we know how
to make
efficiently as I go from level one to
level two right then I have to decide
know which combinations of building
blocks to put together right maybe in
this node now I take building block one
and building block two
and I as I go to level three now I have
to decide which chemical reaction to
apply to this combination of building
blocks right so here maybe I'll apply
reaction 27 and then output of at level
three then will be a more complex
molecule right so you can imagine next
we keep going down this tree right as
the further down we go the more complex
molecules we can get and what's nice
about this tree representation right is
that each path of the tree from The
Roots right to level one two and three
to the lead Leaf right corresponds to
actually a very explicit recipe for how
to make the more complex molecules at
the leaf right in this case now says I
go and take building block one add
building block two apply reaction 27 is
how I get this node this Leaf
node so this is sort of the
representation that we want to work with
the problem here is that this is an
extremely large like an astronomically
large uh tree that we have to search
over and this is where we can try to use
AI to help us to efficiently search this
space
so the way intuitively that this works
is that basically to help us to guide
which part of the tree to search right
we built uh another AI model which is
called a property predictor is you can
view this is providing some sort of
reward to say how promising it is to
explore a particular part of this
chemical tree right so this property
predictor is basically a model that we
trained on a bunch of experimental data
where we actually have collected drug
screen data right and we train a machine
learning model which like a graph neural
network to PR predict how for a given
new molecule right How likely is it to
have some antibiotic properties right so
once we train this property predictor
then we use it to basically we apply it
to evaluate each of the new molecules in
the tree right and say okay and these
new molecules W have some sort of score
right and that score then can be back
propagated up to this this path to also
to provide a score for the building
blocks to see how promising that
building block is for for leading to a a
useful uh Dr
and in addition to this property
predictor right so there's actually a
bunch of other considerations that we
want to encode when we try to discover
new molecules for drugs right so
efficacy is certainly one important
consideration so that's captured by this
property predictor so efficacy here
means How likely is this molecule to be
a good antibiotic molecule right we also
have want to have molecules that are
structurally novel right basically it's
different from molecules that we've seen
before and the reason why structural
novelty is use here it's because know if
it's novel then it's less likely for
existing pathogens to have resistance to
those drugs of course we wanted the
drugs to be safe for humans right so
safety is consideration and also as we
said before we want this to be very easy
to
synthesize
right basically we into Essen the
scoring function that we appli to score
each of these nodes right each of the
combinations and then the basically the
g v model B uses this Square function as
a guide to then explore uh different
parts of the search space to look for
the molecules that have the highest
score right that that has the best
metrics along each of these different
axes so all of this so this is sort of
the the generative a model we call syn
syo right that's developed here at
Stanford and this is where this old
developed this is computation algorithm
is all trained in
Silicon so after we trained and built
this model right so so then the fun part
comes next now we actually get to
synthesize these molecules in the lab
and really test do they
work so to do this uh we work with our
actually enamine which a a company based
in Ukraine right so they specialize
actually in in uh making small
molecules right so we sent 70 recipes
created by our syal AI model to and the
so each of these recipe then corresponds
to basically a path from the root to a
leaf right so it corresponds to
basically a new small molecule and also
a step-by-step set of instructions for
how to make that small
molecule so all of these 70 recipes
corresponds to 70 entirely novel
molecules basically that have never been
synthesized before have never been seen
before on on earth right um and I guess
the interesting thing is that because
enemy bace in Ukraine that you can
imagine that they have a lot of other
constraints over the past year uh
including uh especially with the work
going on in the
background so basically they were not
able to do a lot of optimizations of
these recipes in other words that the
recipes that produced by the AI model
should be extremely simple and very
robust right even without too much
tweaking optimization people should be
to just follow the recipes and make the
molecules and remarkably it actually
worked quite well right so enemy was
able to synthesize 58 of the 70 new
molecules right these correspond to now
novel molecules that are potentially
drug candidates for antibiotics right so
the hit rate here would be over 80% in
terms of the success for synthesizing
these molecules right so this validated
already one of the key components of our
model which is actually create molecules
that are easy to synthesize because by
providing this explicit
recipe so then we basically take these
molecules bring them back right from
Ukraine and then our collaborator John
Stokes group um was able to validate
these molecules right so what they do
here is that we basically have four
extremely dangerous pathogens they are
called Escape
pathogens it's considered to be by the
World Health Organization who to be the
highest priority of pathogens because
they have developed resistance against
many of the existing drugs so this
includes this as B bani like this
perfect Predator we saw before and also
several other
pathogens and then what we did so
basically we tested each of these 58
novel AI designed molecules against all
four of these Escape pathogens to see
how effective it is the molecules are at
killing these
pathogens and among these we identifi
basically six novel antibiotic molecules
that are produced by the AI these six
have shown to be very effective in
killing all four of the pathogens right
so they work quite well across the
board uh in in in
experiments and we did some additional
testing right to show that these six new
molecules are effective right they're
active even when they're used as at low
dosage so this is important because if
you can they're if they're effective at
low dosage then it means that they're
also less likely to lead to side effects
in in in patients we have Mouse model
studies animal studies to show that
these these new drugs they have uh few
signs of toxicity which is also a
promising initial signal to show that
they are potentially saving humans and
we also follow uh know we apply these
new drugs right we also follow them over
time to see that there's actually low an
microbial resistance that's developed
against these new molecules which is
also promising so I think all of these
are very exciting experimental results
that validates the some of the efficacy
and potential safety of these new
molecules that designed by the AI
systems of course this is just uh still
an early step right we need to do
additional clinical trials to validate
these molecules in in patients but I
think this is already showing a lot of
promise for seeing how we can use
generative AI to help us to explore
right entirely new spaces of small
molecules and also to produce new
molecules and also instructions how to
make these new molecules right that are
easy to follow and likely be
effective okay so this is the first
example of in the early stages of of uh
the biomedical research and Discovery
pipeline right how we can actually use
gen of AI to help us to explore new
designs and new in this case new
drugs so now that imagine that you know
you have produced some new drugs right
so typically the next step in this
pipeline is to you want to start to
design clinical trials to test these new
drugs right so for the next vignette I
want to give is how we I want to
demonstrate how we actually use these AI
algorithms to help us to generate
designs of clinical trials right was the
goal of making clinical trials both more
efficient and also more inclusive
so clinical trials is really the the
bottom like and also the gatekeeper of
medical research and medicine right so
you can start with hundreds of great
ideas promising new drug candidates and
they have to go through different phases
of clinical trials to test for efficacy
and safety and only one of these 100
great candidates can actually make it to
the patients right uh because many of
them actually failed the different
clinical trials right and because each
trial itself can cost on the wers of T
sometimes hundreds of millions of
dollars right so then accounting for all
these failed trials right the cost
average cost of bringing a drug to
patient then several billions of dollars
right so then anything that we can do to
make the trials right more effective and
also more efficient then can be really
broadly impactful for the entire medical
translation
pipeline that's motivated us to see how
we can use G of AI to help to improve
the designs of clinical trials and I
want to describe to you one uh method uh
platform that we built called trial
Pathfinders that was described in in
this paper that we publish in nature and
this Tri Pathfinder um I'm excited to
say that it's actually now also being
used by several Pharma bch companies uh
for to help to guide the designs of
their new cancer trials this is work as
SL by richan L who was an excellent PhD
student working with me at
Stanford so here's the setup of the
problem right basically we want use um
AI to help us to decide which patients
to enroll into the clinical trials so
why do we want to look at this patient
enrollment right so the clinical trials
is actually uh very complex because they
are uh extremely selective in What
patients enoll right so let's say if you
look at a child looking at a particular
disease maybe lung cancer right so among
all the patients that have that disease
only a very small fraction of these
patients are actually eligible to
participate in the clinical trials under
the current designs of these trials
right so for example each clinical trial
would have pages right of criteria to
filter out patients some of the patients
might be filtered out because they have
different comorbidities or maybe some of
their lab values are outside of the
range right or because they have
different previous conditions or
different subtypes right so these
patients are all filtered out so there
so the remaining patients are often
called by the industry like called these
Olympic athletes of the patients right
so many of these trials are looking for
these Olympic athletes of the patients
to because they're thought to be like
the safest patients to enroll in these
trials but this overly restrictive
filtering of patients is a huge barrier
right so it means that many of the
patients who actually want to
participate in clinical trials to get
access to the latest treatments they're
not eligible right so hurts those
patients actually also hurts the drug
developers because a large number of
clinical trials have a fa a big
challenge in enrolling enough patients
right and also means that um because
these trials are enrolling these Olympic
athletes of the patients how well the
treatments work on these Olympic
athletes of patients may not reflect how
well the treatments work on the everyday
patients like us so there's a huge
distribution shift right um so for all
these reasons right people are
increasingly recognizing and calling for
clinical trials to be more inclusive and
more
diverse and the Big Challenge right in
designing CL TR that the current way
that we design these TR are oftenly
anecdotal right so here's just an
example right um where the details are
not very important but each row here
corresponds to uh a par particular
eligibility rule that's used to filter
out patients right so basically the
first one just says that if a particular
lab value called a neutral fill account
is outside of some range and those
patients are not
eligible I actually took a screenshot of
this you know from a trial that's being
designed design in progress what's
interesting is that you can actually see
some comments in the the Google Doc
right for Designing of STW where
somebody actually suggested can we
actually relax that threshold to enroll
more patients right and then a third
person says that well know we don't
really have evidence to decide how much
to relax it by right so that's then just
use the more conservative more strict
thresholds that was used before you can
see that there's actually a lot of
interest right in changing the different
designs of the tri to enroll more
patient s right um but often the big
challenge is that we don't really have a
great datadriven way to help us to
decide how much to set these different
thresholds and this is really a huge
problem across the board right so for
example the US National Cancer Institute
has a mandate right that all of the
cancer clinical trials really should be
simplified to enroll more patients but
how to really Design This eligibility
criteria right for these trials that's
still a big open Challenge and this is
where we think sort of data data science
and generative AI could be
helpful so so this is what motivated us
to to to develop this Tri Pathfinder AI
approach right so here's really the high
level idea of how this approach Works
basically we're going to use AI
algorithm right to generate clinical
trials designs right this AI algorithm
is going to be using real world data
basically EHR data of large number of
patients to computationally emulate
clinical trials and it's going to use
those emulations to help to guide the
designs of new
trials right and for this emulation uh
we're going to use uh we use this uh
large data sets uh collected by the flat
iron Network which uh contains data from
over 280 cancer hospitals clinics in the
US over 2 million patients it's it's a
really nice longal data set of all these
different
patients so here's illustration of how
this AI generation of clinical trial
design works right so the goal of this
is to basically have the AI algorithm to
basically generate or propose trial
eligibility rules right like we s talked
about before you can think of the trial
eligibility rules as basically a set of
criteria to decide which patients are
eligible to participate or not eligible
to participate in a given clinical trial
so first thing we can do is to basically
start with the existing clinical trials
right and have the AI algorithm to start
with that as the starting point right so
each of these ibility rules correspond
to like a mathematical constraint you
can think of that as a mathematical
constraint to filter out patients and
there could be dozens of these
eligibility
rules and then what our AI Alm does is
that it's going to take a particular set
of proposed eligibility rules for
clinical trial right and then goes into
the medical records of these millions of
cancer patients from hundreds of
hospitals and then it is basically
creates a digital cohort of patients
right that's taking the relevant
treatment and also satisfies all of
these eligibility rules rules and also
creates like a a comparison cohort of
patients that's taking the same
treatment but may not satisfy all of the
rules maybe they they only uh they miss
some of these eligibility rules right
but they're taking the same treatment
and because we have the laudal EHR data
of all these patients then the
algorithms basically going to follow and
look at the outcomes like the safety and
the survival outcomes of these two
groups of patients and see is there
actually a difference right if there's a
difference that means that maybe there
is some differences that can be
attributed to the specific eligibility
rules if there's less of difference
right that means that we can potentially
BR uh relax some of the rules to enroll
more patients so that's the high level
intuition right so then the algorithm
looks at the out like the simulation
results of the trial and then it goes
back to see okay so how can it change
some of the eligbility rules Maybe by
relaxing some of the uh what happens by
if it Rel relaxes some of the
eligibility rules right so it it
proposes like a new design of the trial
and then it goes back to the to the EHR
data to emulate this new design right so
now because by relaxing the eligibility
rules now there are more patients that
are eligible right and then it can
assessed outcomes right so the key thing
to note here is that this is all done on
already collected observational data
right so this is all done in silicle
which means that it's actually
relatively easy for the algorithm to
generate a lot of emulation trials and
then to get the data back and get the
signal back quite
quickly so to summarize right so the
trial passer is this overall approach
right so it uses the EHR data from a
large cohort of patients and then uses
this AI approach to help to design to
generate new eligibility criteria right
uh and it basically runs millions of
these in cical trials in parallel right
and it then agregates all that
information together to propose uh a
data driven suggestion for how to design
a particular trial right for for a
particular trial right so this is the
output of the model would then always
say okay for for a given trial then here
are some of the eligibility criteria
that are really important right and then
some of other eligibility criteria could
potentially be broadened be relaxed to
enroll more patients right so that's the
recommendation that the model provides
to the the clinical study
teams so we applied this algorithm right
to a variety of different diseases but
um
here I just want to show you the results
from applying it to Advanced noal cell
lung cancer which is one of the most
prevalent forms of
cancer so here are 10 different um
clinical
trials so these are phase two and phase
three trials so the last row is
basically the average results across
these 10 different trials so we can
mostly focus on the last row just to
make things a bit simpler so basically
the first two numbers indicate that if
we actually use the standard design
designs the original designs of these
clinical trials here's how many patients
we be able to enroll right about 1500
patients on average for these trials and
then what is the hazard ratio for these
patients right the hazard ratio
basically measuring what is the survival
outcome of patients for taking the
treatment compared to toward taking
maybe standard of care right so lower
the hazard ratio means the trial that
the drugs more effective if you want it
to be lower the
better so that's the first two rows if
we use the the standard designs of the
trials first two numbers that's last two
numbers corresponds to if we actually
use the AI proposed alge designs of
these trials we see that on average we
can more than double the number of
eligible patients so that's great and in
addition even though the AI will be
enrolling more patients we actually see
a comfortable maybe even a little bit
smaller Hazard ratio right which
suggests that even though we will be
enrolling some of this less like sicker
patients right but the sicker patients
actually do respond to treatment
comfortably or even better than the the
very healthy Olympic athletes among the
patients and I think this is an
important Insight right because the
algorithm actually has learned that by
enrolling right by broadening some of
relaxing some of the eligibility rules
it's able to enroll a lot more patients
and in particular these patients then
will still be able to benefit from the
treatment safely all right and as a
consequence of this the Alm is actually
able to enroll enable a lot more women
more minorities and also older patients
to be able to participate in these
clinical trials
right uh many of these groups are
filtered out by these very overly
restrictive eligibility rules but the
algor actually learned that we don't
need to be so restrictive right we can
still enroll a lot more of these groups
of like minorities of women but really
have uh um no without increasing the
harm or increasing the side
effects so so this is I think a really
promising first step right of how we can
actually use AI to to generate know
really data driven designs of course um
know AI is really just making
suggestions right so the final this
really just additional information that
the clinical study human researchers can
incorporate in helping them to make the
final design so the humans are still
making the final decisions of of the
clinical trials but by providing this
sort of data driven guidance this can at
least provide more information that can
help make make trials more inclusive and
also more diverse uh I didn't have time
to go into details here but in the paper
we actually validate these results from
the AI driven trials us seeing data from
actual clinical trials from also from
other
cohorts and we applied it to cancer to
lung cancer but this can methodology can
also be applied to many of these other
uh
diseases I'm also extremely happy that
this has gotten a lot of traction in the
Pharma industry it was actually uh
selected as one of the top uh data
science Innovations by the Pharma
industry
okay great so now if we're following our
um pipeline right so we talked about
early stage discoveries and how to
design clinical trials and last part I
want to mention is how we can actually
use gener AI to help us at the final
stage right so after you have these
trials you have these drugs that come on
the
market it's still a very challenging
problem for clinicians right this to
diagnose patients uh and to decide which
drugs to give to a particular patient
and this is where we've been develop the
sort of AI chat Bots right language
models that can help as a assistant to
these
clins so I want to give one example of
this right or we we developed AI chat Bo
to help pathologist right so pathology
is really sort of the Pathologists are
people who have to help to diagnose
patients right and they also help to
inform treatment planning and they often
looking at these images right of from
the taken from the tissue biopsies of
the patients and to help them with these
diagnosis
and it's a quite challenging job right
because they can offer encounter images
that come from different body parts from
different diseases that are very uh
unfamiliar to them that they are very
heterogeneous and something really
interesting happens when Pathologists
encounter images that are unfamiliar to
them that many of these pathologist
actually go on Twitter they go on social
network social media right so here are
just a few screenshots I took right of
um pathologist posting images on Twitter
right uh know these are high quality
images that are deidentified so they
feel comfortable posting these and then
they actually invited their colleagues
right from around the world to have a
discussion of how to interpret this
image as so you can see a Twitter thread
of people the clinicians Pathologists
from around the world chiming in in
interpreting And discussing each of
these
images you know it might be surprising
to some of you that your doctors are
usually going on to Twitter and using
Twitter to ask for for help with
interpreting images but this is actually
recommended practice right for example
the US Academy of Pathologists actually
recommend that their members would use
social media as a way to share
knowledge right and we thought this is
actually really great data resource for
building AI models right because here
you have both the images and also
discussions of these images right by the
human experts right and this is actually
great data for helping to teach like a
chat bot right like chat GPT type chat
bot to how to to interpret and help
human Physicians right in interpreting
And discussing these kind of uh
difficult
images okay so this is what motivate us
to create uh this uh uh this data set so
we call open path so basically to create
open path data set we first just go
through all of Twitter to curate these
high quality medical images along with
corresponding expert discussions all
right so to do this we actually use use
specific hashtags that are often
recommended used by the in individual
communities right when they're uh to to
describe their images right for example
different sub areas of pathology like
renal pathology surgical pathology or
breath pathology have their own hashtag
that they that their members use right
so that we use that hashtag to basically
help us to create an initial pool right
of millions of of Twitter
threads now the data from Twitter can be
very noisy right so then we did a lot of
very strict filtering to remove low
quality images and low quality text
right so for example to remove low
quality images we actually built another
machine learning classifier to evaluate
the image quality right and we use that
classifier to basically remove the low
quality images and similarly we have
another classifier that looks at the
text from Twitter and to remove
lowquality or irrelevant text right so
there are several rounds of filtering
and after we do those filtering we're
still left with over 200,000 highquality
Twitter threads
which is currently one of the largest
such public data set right of pathology
images and
discussions um and then once we have
this so basically each Twitter thread
then would have like you know one or
more high quality images right that's
matched with the
corresponding uh interpretations by the
clinicians and then the next step is
that now once we've cured this large
data sets right which is actually by the
way it's all publicly available right
other people can also use this data set
then we train our own
open source visual language model to
help to on this data to help us uh to
interpret these images so this is like a
visual language chat bot right so if you
think about um so basically you can give
it an image and the chat bot then would
have would be able to generate
discussions around that image right so
the way that's trained is that to
basically have like a a text encoder and
image encoder and this is how many of
these chat Bots are trained right so the
idea here is the text encoder then we'll
look at the text information in this
case it could be from Twitter the
Twitter the tweets right and then
extracts information from the text and
the image encoder right would look at
the images and extract features or
embeddings from from each of the
individual pathology images medical
images and then the key part for
building these algorithms that we need
to basically align the text
understanding with the image
understanding so to in order to teach
the chat boot right how to interpret a
given image so to do that alignment is
where we use the Twitter data because we
have the paired images along with the
corresponding conversations and
dialogues about that image right from
each tweet so then we use that paired
information of the text and images to
basically align these two encoders and
output of that is what we call the plip
algorithm right so this is basically
being trained so pre-trained on large
Corpus of natural images and text and
then we fine-tuned it on the pathology
data that we have collected from
Twitter so here's um an example of how
this uh flip uh is used by some of our
colleagues at Stanford Pathology
Department right so the pathologist
actually could upload an image maybe
this is the image that they would like
to get some assistance in helping to
interpret right and then the flip chat
bot would then look at this image and
it'll first provide some descriptions
about what is in the image in this case
it says that you know this is a h& image
of the kidney there's about 700 cells in
the image and there's some inflammation
necrosis right in this image and then
the clinici can also ask questions right
in the model then will also provide
interpretations and response to those
questions based on its interpretation of
the
image so in some cases right our
pathology colleagues uh may not trust
the generation of these chatbots because
of the risk of
hallucination so to address that we
actually buil a second use mode of this
model right instead of trying to
generate its own interpretation of the
image what the model flip does is it
actually goes to retrieve similar imag
have and and discussions of similar
images either from Twitter or from
textbooks or some internal EHR databases
right it finds all those relevant images
extracts of those and provide that and
also summarizes those information for
the user right and this I think
pathology is actually find to be even
more helpful because even if they do not
trust the generation of the model itself
they often still would like to see how
that their colleagues have discussed
similar cases previously right and by
retrieving the similar cases and
summarizing that that still provides
very useful information to help the
clinician so there's a lot more
information about this Chaplet model uh
that was recently cover uh published a
few months ago in nature
medicine um and we really view that this
is a sort of like semantic search engine
right for medicine right for especially
for pathology here the the users can
type in in texate what kind of things
they're looking for and the model them
will retrieve relevant images they can
also just upload an image and the model
will also find similar cases before and
summarize the
text it's a public available search
engine and all of this is open
source so the last part I want to
mention uh you know not that we talked
about about the exciting applications of
generative AI I just want to end by also
giving some caveats right so I think um
this AI tools can be very powerful but
there are also a lot of important
questions that we need to answer
especially thinking about the potential
biases these gener AI models so this is
a paper that we published um last year
where we basically studied different
kinds of stereotypes and biases in these
image generation models like d and
stable diffusion right so for example if
you take stap of diffusion or do and you
type okay I want image of a software
developer here's basically the kinds of
images it would generate right this are
actual output from staple diffusion and
you can see that um there's a really uh
a strong kind of stereotype of what this
AI model believes to be like a
stereotypic software engineer right in
particular right there's only I think
less than 1% of the generations uh of
software developers are actually women
and similarly right these gener models
also have a strong bias stereotype of
what a poor person would look like or a
terrorist would look like or a thug
would look like right these are all
example images that are generated by the
model we use these uh queries
right so we in this previous paper we
sort of we systematically Quantified
that these current generative AI models
especially text to image models do
contain quite a bit of these stereotypes
and biases right and I think this is
still a really important open problem
for the community to address and to be
certainly to be aware of as we're using
these
models so just to wrap up the discussion
right so here um we have discussed
different areas of how we can actually
use gen AI across the bi medical
translation pipeline right for early
stages we've seen how we can actually
use these tools as a way to help us to
explore new spaces of molecules and
we've seen an application of how to use
this to generate new and to validate new
antibiotics right clinical trials as we
go to the go down the medical
translation pipeline clal Tri is a key
bottleneck right and we see examples of
how we can use genbi tools like trial
Pathfinder to help us to design the
eligibility rules of clinical trials to
make these CR more inclusive and more
efficient right and lastly we're also
seeing how we can actually develop New
Gen of AI models like especially visual
language chatbots to help assistance to
Pathologists right to clinicians and
throughout all this know I think it's
really important to think about how to
evaluate and quantify and reduce
mitigate biases in gen of AI
models so here again are the references
based on our works and I want to
especially acknowledge again my students
at Stanford that led all these works
right Rich Kyle and PTO Rico as well as
our fantastic collaborators especially
Ryan copin team at gench uh who a close
collaborator on these clinical trial
part and John Stokes from MCM and his
lab was a very close collaborator on the
drug design side so I'll stop here and
happy to take any questions James thank
you so much that was fascinating uh
congrats to you and and your team for
really putting together a a great
program for you know not only drug
Discovery or antibiotic Discovery but
also um coming up with the uh way to
kind of create a bigger space in the
clinical trial domain um and as well as
some of the uh stuff you did with with
plip I think that seems like a very
powerful tool one thing I just wanted to
get your comments on is I noticed that
you had um you had created uh 70
different antibiotic candidates and 58
got tested and proved to have some
worthwhile to them but there were like
12 that didn't work do you know why the
12 didn't
work question so there that um was not
able to be synthesized at high Yol right
so basically we sent these recipes to
enemy in Ukraine and they were not able
to follow uh the recipes exactly on
those 12 uh on those handful of the
molecules and there's a few reasons why
that happens right sometimes um the AL
on the AI model believes that a
particular chemical reaction is
compatible with certain building block
fragments right but in reality maybe
those are hard to put together or are
not very efficient in the lab right so I
think that's one common reason why that
that did not work or could also be that
some of the building blocks may not have
been available to
enemy and I I I liked what you
demonstrated with the ability to create
the molecules and then go you know
create as many as you can resolve with
the your your company and then test them
against known pathogens and you know
then you'll you'll kind of know if you
kill those off with your you know which
which ones kill those off you can
identify which ones might be helpful I'm
curious if you can kind of do that
process in Reverse is there anything
that you can know a priori about the
pathogens and help guide the model
creation um or the the molecular
creation of your antibiotic candidates
so kind of like scale down the
parameterize this the search space
that's a great question um and I think
that is actually something we're
actively working on right because
ideally I view this like a feedback loop
right where yeah we first generated a
batch of molecules we test those against
the real pathogens in the lab now we
have additional data that can then go
back and help us to guide the designs of
even the next generation of new drugs
right so the model is becomes much more
efficient going forward so we're
actually imp know implementing that
whole feedback loop and I I you're
absolutely right I think there's a lot
of actually information that the model
does learn from the initial experiments
that help us that helps the model to
explore more efficiently in the future
and can you make predictions from those
um antibiotics for example which are
successful can you get a sense of their
the bacteria's resistance to it or
rather not immediate obviously it kills
it but could you identify places where
the bacteria might start to find
resistance against it and then somehow
kind of head that off at the past to
extend the the lifetime of the efficacy
of that particular um antibiotic so I
think that's that's a really good idea
and I think that that is uh the type of
information that the model will be able
to learn at leverage right so for
example when we train the current model
we actually give it a lot of existing
data from previous drug screens against
other pathogens right so the model does
learn some information about what are
the kinds of Mo molecular motifs that
are more likely to be effective uh
against certain bacteria yeah right so
it's started it's so it's sort of it is
bootstrapping off some of that prior
knowledge and domain knowledge to help
to guide to the search space and once
you discover these things let's say you
you found that uh out of the ones that
you created you found that six were
successful they they of those they were
able to kill off four of the six test
pathogens that you gave to it but let's
say you find some that are particularly
successful do you share the openly share
the recipe with people or is there some
drug company that wants to snarf this up
and go make a lot of
money yes so that's a great question so
so everything we did here is all open
source right so we actually also made
the the AI model itself open source as
well as the the products right the
discoveries of the AI model right uh and
the reason why we did this is to really
I think know we want to basically help
other people to basically use this
algorithm as well to discover new drugs
in their own space I think there's you
know there's a broad moral ethical kind
of question as well which I think
actually because you mentioned um
Alexander Fleming and when he discovered
penicillin he gave it away because he
felt that it was important for the world
and that he didn't want it to become the
purview of some foreign company that was
just going to go and and make a lot of
money off it so he he gave it away and
there's you know some of the work that
you're doing is seems to be in that
spirit it and then giving it away for
free certainly doubles down on that that
kind of notion that this is stuff that
um you know should be shared with the
world so that People's Health can be
protected and maintained and that people
can then build on these ideas and and
make them stronger so uh I I was
impressed with that kind of idea and I
also like the your idea of kind of like
looking to see how you can use the the
um the trial Pathfinder to actually kind
of optimize your your clinical trial
work so that you you're not always
looking at these Olympic Athlete test
subjects um but you're you're able to
actually broaden things in a very
informed way and I'm curious if you once
you identified these um kind of
optimized sets of parameters do you then
out those through say human clinical
trialists to see whether or not those
look like they're reasonable or that you
can get you know feedback from a human
who expert in clinical trial or
certainly domain experts to see whether
or not those things are are actually
doable exactly yes yeah so it's very
much a collaboration between the AI
model and the human clinical trial teams
right then we go through SI through all
those data from millions of uh EHR
records right and then propose this data
driven design of the eligibility rules
of the clinical trials and then that
become basically become one source of
information that the cl technal trial
teams or the human experts would use to
help them to guide the designs of the
trials um so ultimately the the human
teams in our studies in our
collaborations they do evaluate right
the designs of the AI model uh and in
these cases we looked at for example in
the lung cancer cases the designs the AI
model is actually very reasonable to the
humans right uh in particular there are
actually a lot of instances in the past
where the either by chance or
anecdotally where some of the actual L
clinical trials end up looking very
similar to the AI ones right U because
there's a huge amount of heterogeneity
that are uh in people how people design
these trials and that's actually one
source of information that we can use to
further validate that the AI proposed
designs are
recable so in our last couple of minutes
here I'd like to you know what you're
presenting here are ways that I think
are Paradigm shifting for how people do
drug Discovery and certainly um things
like antibiotic looking at e antibiotic
efficacy and you know the various
properties of its success um you're
almost touching on personalized levels
of antibiotic kind of creation right you
could almost tailor this uh some of your
trial Pathfinder related work so you can
actually dovetail those and given some
of the other things that you you've
optimized here you're really trying to I
don't know I get the sense that this is
really kind of Paradigm shifting for how
you would train the incoming generation
of people who do this type of research
whether it's drug Discovery or whether
it's um uh clinical trials how do you
see these kinds of things influencing
education and are there any things that
we need to be thinking about as we start
thinking about you know okay in the next
20 years this is what people are going
to do when they do this type of work any
thoughts on that yeah thank you for that
I think that that's a really interesting
question uh we actually have um sort of
like a
a perspective paper coming out um
thinking B thinking through like how
what should for example data Science
Education look like right in with all
these general of AI tools like chat GPT
right uh and I
think at the education level I think
there's a really tremendous opportunity
right how how we can actually use these
gener AI tools responsibly right as a
part of Education right um and certainly
I think we want to think through how can
we teach our students and the future
researchers of what are good ways of
using language models and using chat gbt
to help them to assist their research
and also like maybe what are not so good
ways right uh that they that they want
to avoid right but overall I think one
area where I think these models can be
very useful for helping future
researchers and in education and also in
in their own research going forward is
really as a way to help us to help them
to generate new ideas
right because these models have seen so
much of the literature right much more
they've read a lot more papers than we
would have have even have time to ever
possibly read right so I think there are
a good way of sort of summarizing
literature and then try to identify gaps
in literature and gaps in and propose
new ideas that would potentially spark
some creative ideas for the human
researchers well James thank you so much
for sharing this with us this was really
inspiring and this is
absolutely a mountainous amount of work
so congratulations to you and to your
team and thank you for sharing much yeah
yeah and uh thank you everybody who uh
is watching or will soon watch us on
YouTube and uh everyone have a